So let's get back to our Klout score example. Based on the fact that our sample
mean was 40 of everyone who used the Bieber Tweeter our population mean could
range from 34.58 to 45.42. And we found that the original population mean 37.72,
is well within this interval. Basically this means that a sample of size 35 with
a mean of 40 could have been selected by random chance. It's very possible. But
what about in our second example from lesson 7 where we got a mean Klout score
of 40 again but with a sample size of 250. Now our sampling distribution becomes
a lot skinnier because we have a much bigger sample size. So this is about 1.01.
So now if we a 95% confidence interval for what the mean Klout score would be if
everyone used the Bieber Tweeter, will the range be bigger or smaller than the
one you calculated when the sample size was 35.